well all week we are taking you to
Anaheim California thanks to visit
Anaheim the sponsors of this segment we
had a chance to check out some of the
festive happenings going on in Southern
California here's a look at Knott's
Berry Farm
what began as a roadside Berry stand and
chicken dinner restaurant in the 1920s
has evolved into an iconic Southern
California theme park destination
Knott's Berry Farm here you can find
roller coasters a wild wild west
experience and a warm welcome into the
peanuts family and every holiday season
the park transforms into Knott's Mary
farm so excited that you're here at
Knott's Berry Farm I'm getting to
celebrate with us not merry Farm
starting November 18th extending all the
way through January 8th and now as you
walk in through those days you're
transforming your you're seeing our
backdrop of Knott's Berry Farm
celebrating Christmas in his Christmas
decor everywhere and it's absolutely
beautiful expect to see Magical Lights
dancing toys and holiday shows now what
I am super excited about this year aside
from our robust entertainment that we
have two shows I'm very specifically
excited about are it's our brand new two
offerings over at the Walter not there
we have a brand new ice show it's
Snoopy's nights before Christmas and
we're celebrating our 40th year doing
ice shows here with a brand new show
from ice skating to lighting up the sky
on top of having ice skaters on the ice
we've taken it up in the sky as well
when we have featured aerialists that we
have for snoopies nights before
Christmas and that's going to be over at
the Walter not theater we may be in
Southern California but will we see a
little snowfall while we're walking
around yes absolutely so using a Calico
as our backdrop we're taking this little
old west as you always get transported
to when you come to Knott's Berry Farm
but we have snow and glow during our
evening time the town comes to life we
have our beautiful lights that start to
twinkle we have traditional Christmas
music that starts to play and of course
we have snow you can't have Christmas
without snow right
just growing up in Las Vegas I would
come to Knott's Berry Farm all the time
we were talking a little bit about it
before it just it feels like home and it
just feels so special when you walk
through those Gates what do you love
most and what do you hope people take
away when they leave the park for me
personally when I get to come to the
park what I love is just the essence of
Christmas that you get when you're here
right you get to see our wonderful
Christmas trees you get to see our
performers in front of the trees and you
get that feeling of oh my goodness I'm
with my family this is a tradition that
I get to be here Knott's Berry Farm
isn't complete without the food and
holiday Classics we have so much fun
food that we have this year one of my
favorite things is we have our cookie
decorating we're actually standing uh
right where you can decorate some
cookies and we couldn't leave the park
without going on a roller coaster well
Chris and I are about to go on the Ghost
Rider are you ready to go on Southern
California's longest wooden roller
coaster I'm ready let's do it let's go
to my favorite rides it's really fast
and really fun
we made it we made it it was fast our
eyes are watering but it was so much fun
you gotta check out the Ghost Rider and
Knott's Berry Farm happening too
and now is your chance to win a
two-night stay at the JW Marriott
Anaheim Resort tickets to a hockey game
at the Honda Center and a four pack of
tickets to Knott's Marion Farm just go
to 8newsnow.com and enter today's
keyword which is California
well moving